Speaker 1: I'm going to play a clip for you
here of Ted Cruz being interviewed on Newsmax.
And you're going to hear the Newsmax host say
something that is becoming a story about Tim
Scott. And it's a similar story as it is with
Lindsey Graham, the other Republican senator
from South Carolina. And the way that Newsmax
frames it is that there are questions about Tim
Scott's personal life. Now you might be saying,
What do you mean, questions about his personal
life? I need to be crystal clear with you about
what they mean here. They are starting to allude
to the possibility that Tim Scott is gay. They
always dance around it. I'll explain it in a
moment. Take a listen to this. And I'm and what if
you're watching Watch Ted Cruz when this comes up.
Speaker 3: Glad for for Tim's voice. I think he's
a very important voice in the Senate. And I'm sure
he will add a lot to this race. Yeah. So amazing
life story, personal story. But we don't know a
lot about his personal life. And at some point,
those questions will be asked as we make our way
closer to especially August, the debate stage in
Milwaukee. You have a comment on that? Oh, look,
I'm sure that there will be nasty political.
Speaker 1: Attacks between the different
candidates in the primary that Ted Cruz is
like. I know there are going to be nasty
political attacks because I'm planning some
particularly disgusting ones myself that.
Speaker 3: We can expect. We've already seen
some of that. And it's a rough and tumble
business. That's that. That's how it operates.
Speaker 1: Okay. So what are they alluding to
here? I'll give you the back story.
And understandably, a lot of people
just haven't heard about this yet. The idea
here is Tim Scott could be gay. He might
be gay. And the right is speculating.
And there are these articles, you know,
57 year old Tim Scott has never been married. He's
a sort of perpetual bachelor, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah. When he entered politics at age 30, he
talked about being a virgin. He attributed it to
his Christian faith or something. But it actually
might be that he's a gay man who is not was not
comfortable saying that publicly. Still isn't
comfortable saying that publicly. Now, I have
absolutely no idea whether Tim Scott is gay. There
are reports he's he's brought women to events at
times before. Doesn't really mean anything one
way or the other. I don't actually care whether
Tim Scott is gay, but the fascinating part is
that the right is setting up the homophobic
line. And with Lindsey Graham, it's sort of the
same thing. Actually, it's not exactly the same.
I don't know where it stands right now, but with
Lindsey Graham, it's considered more of one of
these open secrets. Also a perpetual bachelor,
Lindsey Graham and speculation or discussions
that he's actually a gay man. Why this wouldn't
just be something you say. Well, I think part of
it has to do with you're a senator in a Republican
Party that is still extraordinarily homophobic and
that tells you a lot about why. So as far as
Tim Scott goes, they are starting to prepare
that line of attack. You will not see it brought
out by candidates. Trump and DeSantis aren't going
to on a debate stage. If Tim Scott makes it
to a debate stage, attack him for being gay,
it's just not going to happen. But the PACs and
the dark money, etc. If for whatever reason, Tim
Scott actually started getting some traction in
this primary, which he almost certainly will not,
they can start doing the there are questions about
his personal life thing. It's been done to other
candidates before. That's what's being alluded
to here. It's a horrible thing. It's probably
even more horrible that it has the potential to
impact voters within a Republican primary. We
will follow it. And that's what they're teeing
up. All of these clips that I've been playing,
the Newsmax Ted Cruz clip about Tim Scott or the
earlier clips with Tim Scott on FOX. All of these
clips, we make these available on our Instagram,
which you can find by searching Instagram for
David Packman show. We also post them to our
Tik Tok, which you can find by searching Tik
Tok for David Pakman Show. And of course, we
make them available on our YouTube channel,
which you can find at YouTube.com. Forward
slash, not back, slash forward, slash the David
Pacman show. We're going to take a very short
break and the show continues right after this